[Música]
pienso un segundo en algo que disfrutes
mucho en algo que te gusta y que como te
gusta tanto te gusta compartir piensa en
una buena comida piensa en una buena
canción una buena película nosotros
cuando disfrutamos algo tenemos esta
necesidad natural de quererlo compartir
con las personas que queremos tenemos
esta necesidad se genere nosotros es
decir no me lo quiero quedar solo para
mí sino que quiero que tú también lo
tengas ahora
yo traigo esta caja y en esta caja
traigo un par de cosas que a mí me
gustaría compartir porque porque son
especiales para mí y como lo es especial
para mí a mí me gusta darlo a los demás
en esta caja yo traigo
algunos libros y ahorita me gustaría
leerles un poco voy a leerles este
platón vamos a platicar es increíble
plato vamos a estar aquí con él no vamos
a estar unas dos horas este y al final
vamos a practicar que sentimos claro que
sí como dos horas de plato para ellos
china tengo aquí otros entonces
no no no
entonces no les vengo a compartir algo
que es un poquito distinto
o las microficciones las microficciones
son relatos cortos breves no más de un
minuto tal vez dos y me gustaría que
dado que es algo que a mí me gusta mucho
y que voy a compartir pues que me pongan
atención entonces vamos a ver me busco
uno me dijeron cuál platicará 150 bueno
tenemos alguna oportunidad espero no
regarla puede ser y escogí este
y es de marcial fernández y se llama el
engaño
la conoció en un bar y en el hotel le
arrancó la blusa provocativa la falda en
tallada los zapatos de tacón alto las
medias de seda los ligeros las pulseras
y los collares negros el corsé el
maquillaje y al quitarle los lentes
negros se quedó completamente solo
una micro ficción algo que en un minuto
toda una historia y aquí acaban de
ocurrir varias cosas 1
yo
con algo que me gusta
tu recibiendo algo que a mí me gusta y
haciéndote partícipe de eso ahora yo
puedo platicar contigo de esto que te
acabo de
3 lo que yo siento al compartir sal en
mi gozo eso que que no puedo crear de
otra manera
les voy a platicar una anécdota hace
algunos años más o menos en el 2013
una muchacha de los bigotes me habló y
me dijo oye crees que podamos ir a una
actividad
[Música]
a dónde voy
y ella me dijo no no me está haciendo
unos cuates que se suben a los cambios
malísima en inglés el de un padre así
que ahora la recibamos claro vamos
fue la cinta era una plaza comercial el
domingo 10 de la mañana
diego
juanita con él
adivina qué
qué más urbanita
que no voy a ir
bueno le puedes gritándole pues nos
vemos
cambian
y ya estoy ahí ya estoy en la mitad de
nada este ya me levanté en esto
no sé con quién estoy no los conozco voy
a buscar a la gente rara
ahí hay un grupo de gente extraña camino
hacia ellos y estas personas eran carlón
en su familia pero no es un escritor de
aquí de juárez su esposa sus hijos
amigos de ellos y les digo ustedes que
nosotros
[Música]
ándale pues éste mira esto es lo que
hacemos que hacían ellos se subieron los
camiones tomaban tres rutas de vida tres
rutas de regreso y repartían pequeños
volantes a las personas que estaban en
el autobús y les pedíamos que leyeran
que nos con que nos siguieran
el detalle es que
pues cuando alguien se sube un camión y
te empieza a ofrecer cosas tú le dices
que no joven
tú le dices que no
pero la cosa cambiaba cuando
comenzábamos no des puede ser que era
mágico no debo decir que todos nos
tomamos de los brazos y comenzábamos a
leer y nos íbamos a un mundo mágico no
balona
también hay que ser realistas
poco a poco se iba dando el cambio
despacito no había mucho que buscarle
nosotros dejamos aprendí tuve varias
experiencias que hasta la fecha me han
servido desarrollar habilidades leyendo
en el camión es mágico los invito a que
lo hagan te toman hacia arriba
el libro
[Música]
y viva en una ruta de aquí saben que
tres personas fuerza en los brazos y en
las piernas
y más pues para que no te maree para que
puedas compartir con las personas
nosotros sentíamos que estábamos
haciendo lo correcto nosotros sentíamos
que al compartirle a la gente gente que
no sabía que estaba pasando a gente que
en su vida tal vez había expuesto a
escuchar a una persona a leer de por qué
era un regalo de nosotros hacia ellos y
el regalo que la vida nos daba a
nosotros también a compartir
mil experiencias créanme eso es una
locura estar peleando con los cuates que
venden chocolates y aguas no es te
espero pero al final no lo grabamos
menos tarde pero lográbamos subirnos ya
cuando estábamos arriba
pasaban mil historias
la lectura como la literatura es un arte
y el arte toca el arte agrede te
transforma
claro que siempre como este problema
hemos 9 porque bajas aquí estás
desperdiciando tu domingo porque yo
seguía no se convirtió en un ritual para
mí cada 15 días puntualitos para
erradicar
te vas tú ni sabes el proyecto en sí
la hoja de ruta se llamaba el proyecto
y yo es que estamos haciendo algo bueno
los detalles fue que algunas de esas
experiencias que a mí me marcaron una en
particular
qué pasó nos subimos a la ruta teníamos
de regreso
subimos vi que el camión me tocaba leer
observé que no hubiera tanta gente y la
que había era la gente mayor de edad
entonces dije este texto que traigo lo
puedo compartir porque no vienen niños
cochinos no más éste pusiera un poco
erótico era muy bonito ahora una
historia muy bella comencé a leerlo era
una historia básicamente platicaba como
una chica no más de 16 años se descubría
como mujer se descubría en una tina en
el texto del platicaba donde ponían sus
manos que hacía con ellas como se iba
sintiendo
una lectura preciosa
hermosa pero también
cuando bajo cuando vamos mi mano con mi
folleto
de una vida a la vida
como siete años
y así es no puedo tener
dije oh bueno igual y no entiende nada
no entiendes
así que
bueno los niños preguntan qué tanto base
y la niña comenzó a preguntarle a la
cama
lo que estoy diciendo este loco que
están cambiando
yo no sabía dónde meterme yo no sabía
qué hacer yo tenía mucha pena sobre lo
que había pasado o sea le hablé a una
niña de como otras chicas estaba tocando
o sea muy bonito por cierto super
artístico
pero pero así pasó
afortunadamente la historia salió bien
afortunadamente la mamá me voltea a ver
me pidió que me calmara yo no sabía
dónde
y me pidió que me calmara y me dijo no
pasa nada yo le explico no nos pasa nada
ahorita la niña me pregunta yo le
explico
la
la niña le comenzó a preguntar cosas al
amor
yo me bajé como cualquier persona lo
hubiera hecho
entonces yo me bajé
y se desató una historia por una
tontería por una persona que se subió
con copias a leer en un camión a leerle
a una persona que ni en la vida te hace
y compartirles un minuto de algo que a
ti te gusta
mil cosas más pasaron hay otras que me
gustaría platicar pero
desafortunadamente por cuestiones de mi
trabajo y de mis quehaceres diarios tuve
que abandonar el proyecto me fui el
proyecto pues continuó más o menos unos
ocho meses más seis ocho meses más y
también se puso en pausa indefinida de
hecho ahorita sigue en pausa lo gracioso
es que por ejemplo ellos ahorita édgar
su familia maneja en un proyecto de
biblioteca comunitaria ahí en una
esquina olvidada de la mano de dios'
nadie sabe
nadie les haga reconocimiento a nadie
les da crédito por lo que hacen
pero ellos lo siguen haciendo ellos
siguen desde ese lugar donde están desde
esa trinchera donde están siguen
creyendo que están haciendo lo correcto
con algo tan simple como letras como
alguien leyendo la otra persona siempre
estando en un libro a otra persona
el problema con que con esto es leer es
el siguiente
tenemos muchos prejuicios con la persona
que le creemos que hizo un rayito no
creemos que es un matado creemos que se
pueda bien simple el circo que nosotros
miramos los coros una vez leí no es
cierto no es cierto no es cierto mi ser
total tampoco no son gente intelectual o
sea tranquilos pero tampoco no es gente
intelectual vuestra boca no no no si
alguno de ustedes lo hace si alguno de
ustedes tiene el hábito de la lectura
sabrá que no son raros
sabrán que no son diferentes y viene el
inegi nos menciona que hay un gran
porcentaje de la población que lee
porque ven a alguien que lee porque está
convive con alguien que le es importante
hacerlo
yo no tengo tiempo a leer
nadie tiene preocupado la tuya
metro 1 año
mete un libro en mayo como antes
mascarell ha asegurado meter o cambia
esos 10 minutos esos 15 minutos cambia
lo vas a ver como todo
fluye bonito fluir
de igual menos algo útil
hoy espero que poquito les importa
no importa como por entretenimiento nada
más sale lo puro entretenimiento
danny estoy en la que nos menciona en el
decálogo de los derechos del lector no
mencionan 10 cosas
nos menciona 10 cosas
y varias de ellas a mí me gustan mucho
el primer derecho del lector es el
siguiente no leer
oye esperanza wanda
me estás diciendo que eran 10 minutos 15
[Música]
si no leas lo que no te gusta tan simple
como eso
hay ocasiones en las que esto de la
lectura nos nos ocasiona problemas
porque porque es un castigo nos
enseñaron a que si no hacíamos algo te
va a tocar hacer esto lee lo resume en
aquello de cierto color porque haces
algo tan maravilloso algo que puede
cambiar mi vida que me puede dar
libertad en mi mente porque convertirme
en un castigo porque hacerlo lo que es
tomás que no es no eres un lector si no
has leído esto
no no no
si la verdad o sea las vacas sagradas en
la literatura de las añadas no importa
no soy yo yo también sigo con las leyes
de que no
y ya lo hago porque me gusta lo hago
porque lo disfruto en mi caso yo escojo
leer libros
soy pedante y pretencioso entonces me
gusta leer libros que me exigen y
alternarlos con libros que no me exigen
para que para mantener un equilibrio
porque a mí me gusta eso y es muy
importante eso a mí lo que yo hago
es importante tener este tipo de cosas
presentes además también nos decía que
uno de los derechos de lectores
puedes saltarte páginas no te gusta lo
que están leyendo saltarte la página no
te gusta cómo empieza no le hace el
principio empieza el final si tú quieres
romperse nada es algo que se debe de
guardar no es algo que no es algo más
académico que tengo que estar siguiendo
si estás estudiando si es académico pero
tienes que seguir tienes que seguir
porque es algo que se disfruta es algo
que se hace que existe un gozo en él
también nos menciona uno de los derechos
yo tengo miedo yo tengo derecho al
guarismo
madame bovary que un punto en el que
este personaje de la literatura
confundía la realidad y la ficción yo
tengo derecho a hacer eso yo tengo
derecho a enamorarme de esos personajes
a querer vivir en esos mundos oa no
querer vivir en ellos
o igual la comparamos con la realidad lo
cual es más triste pero yo lo puedo
hacer
es algo que me gusta salem es algo que
me gusta es algo que yo puedo compartir
con los demás
hace tiempo una persona que
desafortunadamente ya no está
era mi gente muy simpático el profesor
y él nos decía que era muy importante
que era extremadamente importante estar
promoviendo la lectura que nos daba
libertad que nos abrían nuevos panoramas
mundos de experiencias y demás no le
creíamos la verdad no le creíamos
pero con el tiempo te das cuenta que si
con la experiencia te das cuenta que si
vuelvo no es un fenómeno místico no es
que yo tomo el libro igual o esté
transportado hermano estoy en este mundo
mágico y todo
cada quien lo vive como quiere y todavía
mejor si tienes alguien con que
platicarlo si tienes alguien con quien
compartirlo adquiere un significado
totalmente distinto no es lo mismo lo
que yo entendí que lo que entender el
otro no es lo mismo y cuando lo platicas
cuando lo platican
se transforma en otra cosa se hace otra
cosa
mi jefe nos decía que con eso me
gustaría terminar su máxima hasta el
final de esos días fue leer nos hace
libres